my name is Tony Bates I'm managing
director of idec's consulting we are a
national business offices in Glasgow
Manchester London and barium
the personal branding program was more
we we had a challenge really we were
using LinkedIn we plan a huge amount of
money for LinkedIn recruitment licenses
but we weren't getting the ROI on that
that we needed really so a lot of the
engagement we get emails we were send
him the response wasn't as high as we
wanted so we wanted to actually show our
consultants personalities and they'll be
online didn't quite know how to do that
obviously we've operate in the same way
for a number of years and the branding
exercise really was was an educational
piece to our consultants to actually for
them to showcase who they are what they
do and what they do well
we've been really surprised by the
results actually the results been superb
and what we found is there's two things
we've had direct results in terms we've
made five placements in our first
quarter on the back of it which was to
the value of about seventy thousand
pounds but also what we found is the
difference in conversations that we have
him with with clients and candidates so
rather than having to do the
introduction of who we are and you know
a little bit of spiel and idec's they
already know so actually the quality of
conversations that we have in on the
back of the branding exercise a higher
quality more engaged and we're getting
better results to resolve it
well I wouldn't recommend it to any
other agencies that specialize in our
sector because we feel like we've got a
genuine advantage by by having that but
so other companies outside of that I
think you know recruitment is renowned
in a certain way and I think it's it's a
it's an opportunity to showcase who you
are what you do and why are you
different so the general theories of
what a recruitment consultant is and how
they operate you know there's some
really good businesses out there some
really good equipment operators the
branding is a way for you to tell the
audience exactly what you do and why
they should work with you but also give
yourself a bit of personality because
obviously people buy people and that's
what it's about